[Music]  real housewives just a little briefly  NeNe Leakes is coming back yes [ __ ] I  am back are you excited  very exciting opportunities but I am a  fan of all of the franchises Atlantis my  favorite and so I'm super excited that  Nene and Kim are coming back because you  kind of can't have one without the other  so I'm super excited about that I make  for interesting TV and I mean it was  their surprise of like Kenya we heard  word it word on the street is that she's  now a missus you talked to her soon  I talked to her before that and she told  me about the guy and she told me she was  in love and I was like okay how you  gonna do this on camera and she was like  girl I don't know and she surprised us  Cole okay do you approve of her new beau  I don't know him but from what she has  told me about him and he seems like he's  fantastic  [Music]